it's a musical ministry yeah a musical
ministry that's now being compared to
fire festival on Friday Kanye West
Sunday service performed at Bethany
Church in Baton Rouge Louisiana
drawing a massive crowd if Pastor
friends are in town they'll come and
they'll say a few words if now you know
it's traveling to other churches it's
just become this amazing thing
and while the concert was free people
could opt in for a fifty five dollar
brunch Ella meal before the show which
was our fundraiser for the church sounds
good right wrong when one concert goer
saw what they were getting for their
money they took to social media to
unleash their outrage writing this is
the wonderful and cold brunch buffet we
are being served and the server looked
at me crazy when I asked for another
pancake yeah that meat it's gray anyway
another person tweeted quote looks like
J's brunch Ella turned out to be brunch
from hella adding hashtag Yeezy fire
fest yeah remember the dumpster fire
that was fire fest and the now-infamous
fire fest cheese sandwiches yeah that's
what people are comparing the brunch
Ella meal to oh I don't care so much so
that the hashtag yeezy fire festival
really made its rounds on the internet
and even 50 cent trolled Kanye tweeting
$55 pancakes what the [ __ ] the caterer
for the event - released a statement to
Daily Mail com defending the food and
the service claiming only one guest was
dissatisfied with their meal quote the
catering company acknowledges it did not
provide adequate food for one attendee
and a social media post went viral but
the food wasn't the only thing about the
gathering that had people comparing it
with a 20-17 festival one concert goer
shared pics of the VIP entrance and a
VIP area which was really just a small
hill that sign though and the cherry on
top Kanye was an hour and a half late to
hit the stage but don't worry in the
meantime a four track playlist played on
a loop for it
these one concert goer tweeted quote
same playlists still on repeat slowly
losing sanity but when he did arrive
Kanye who released his new album Jesus
is king in October post her pics with
fans so that's good
and while Kanye may not have burned
himself any new fans at the Sunday
service he does have one super famous
superfan
I think he's doing something really
special there yep that's Brad Pitt who
was spotted at Kanye Sunday service in
September dishing about his love for the
spiritual event it's just it's pure
celebration of life and people and it's
it's it's really delightful it really is
you know for him it started off as
something that was really healing for
him and it was really small and really
personal and it grew and grew and he
really has been saved by Christ and it's
like born again and he dedicates his
whole life to the church I have to admit
that great sausage patty definitely has
me feeling like I'm going to bomb but I
do love Kanye Sunday service and his new
album so I'm not mad at it of course
et will be right here to keep you in the
know on all things Kanye so make sure to
keep it locked right here on ET until
next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for
now
[Music]